Brahe Santa Barbara yelped it in life is
really good rollin deep and you should
boiling myself cause tomorrow's my
birthday
that works enjoy I know alright good
morning
it's just birthday today we ordered a
champagne breakfast for her birthday got
delivered to her door dead come on eat
if that's what day it is diff Happy
Birthday 327 that's so crazy that's like
my late 20s now it's like my 20s are
slipping through my fingers it's so
weird but yeah I mean it's still pretty
cool though because I still get ID'd
like crazy people still think I'm lunch
21 I know people were giving you a hard
time getting your drinks cuz you look
like you're above 21 well thank you you
know shaved six ears like the one thing
I can never get away with is lying about
my age if you know that I have a son if
you know his age and if you know what
age I was when I had him which was 18
you just gotta do meth anything in love
my age yeah you look like my little
brother you're in YouTube comments I've
read yeah wait so wait their mother and
son of a brothers sister he imagined
mommy being your sister instead I'd be
crazy crazy it is so weird the way
typically parents talk to kids or you
don't use like the words dude or a come
on man
and you do those I like when you say
things like that it does give off like a
very sister brother vibe yeah I try to I
try to be a hip parent you know the cool
mall yeah I think oh you like tell them
do something like come on dude let's do
this one good come to clean hey that's
really cute it just makes them feel like
we're friends we're homey
because you are my best friend know that
my best friend and my best friend loved
it
Oh best friend mother I have to be your
mother let's eat that's a hungry MPEG me
Korbel champagne me champagne whoa
yeah Charlotte crazy where's the cork Oh
where'd it go it's like with me here
hmm I like smelling this gross oh the
cutest tiniest little and I see the
whole Cup it's so cute all right here we
go
[Music]
before you go shower though surprise
down to the death the day you baby you
got me a birthday present that's big and
squishy open it what is it two things
thank you very very color - thank you so
much
I love it thank you it's my favorite
color
you know it's funny I recently bought
Casey a row yeah and I butterbur it was
like you caught me a roll do you want
your birthday present early
I'm like did you get me a rope - he was
like well do you want your birthday
present early I'm like baby you ruined
my brain yeah but I notice this color
Chicka Chicka matches your hair you like
my new robe this is the one that I
bought cake so this is Casey's Rover
that I bought for him and this is my
birthday flipper
semantics oh my goodness your Saha
you're so comfy I read reviews on how oh
cool there's a pocket inside thirsty
sandwich compartment sandwich gum part
of it I'm betting to Kitty the timing is
all off at these things but happy
flowers we're supposed to wake up to
them oh really idea was to wake up
straight to the flowers and then the
food comes and we gonna eat they kind of
came back were delayed for several hours
or an hour thank you I love this
birthday so much I mean it well what is
it did you write a special message a
birthday arrangement from Casey Chen
happy birthday baby a celebration at sea
for a wonder last wife Oh cute kewpie
Emma wanderlust
gonna be wife soon gonna be one yeah oh
not you finished this is a birthday girl
finishing the champagne yeah I'm feeling
good I feel like I'm not as buzz as I
feel is just that the boat about rocks
yeah I feel I'm like whoa am I really
this drunk no pretty crazy okay yes
we're gonna be dropping off Isaac at his
kids club things and then we're gonna be
heading
to our massage and after we knew that
then you're gonna pick me up yeah we're
gonna pick you up for lunch pretty
relaxed with the champagne from this
morning very relaxed - you know what
you're in a futuristic sci-fi movie
right now I didn't like your background
I need you do it's like wall-e GRT
alright we're getting ready for our
massage this is so nice The Pianist bars
in order I know an outdoors massage
sorry I'm like really weak okay that
shouldn't be really kind of got to me
both rock it is rocking a lot but oh
okay well he's getting undressed now see
guys later all right we just finished
our massage it was so amazing even had
these uh hot stones it was long we
actually got a message from a pic while
we're getting a massage she's like can I
go to swim in the pool please hey I'm
cute thank you so much
[Music]
okay yeah I have a very Stephanie or
something
so her dancing last night we went a
basketball playing I did a few
activities walked a lot yesterday and I
felt fine this morning but as a massage
though it triggered like soreness in my
knee and hurts I think is what they call
a stiff knee or a baby that's not that
bad so walking back from the massage we
found Isaac and Kyle swimming and we
found Christina and cannon Bri and so we
all agreed that we're going to come back
to the room change it to our swimming
stuff and then just hang out in the
jacuzzi but then walking back to the
room Casey started like limping all the
massaging is me hoping it'll feel better
if it I don't know their worth
it's always nice and you tend to my side
I never ever need yes we go back to the
room and I saw another surprise look at
this got some chocolate and some more
pastries these are delicious and then we
got some more champagne which we're
gonna need cuz I finished the first
bottle and I really usually don't like
drinking at all but honestly like
drinking helps being on the ship because
this entire time we're just like rocking
back and for drinking that tugs and
keeping myself from getting seasick yeah
so we're gonna change right now and then
we're gonna go Jacuzzi it up let's do it
let's do it alright we're all geared up
for this jacuzzi animals at swimming
pool jacuzzi
dude I'm starting to slur my words hey
Devin again I've been trying to catch up
to this guy he was drinking up all the
champagne I gotta catch up to you there
was a boat yeah drink champagne so
you're glad that we're still inside
I don't be stunner shades style okay
let's both be finish a stout finish a
stout all right let's go Jacuzzi it up
Isaac still up there should we bring
this
[Music]
relax and oh my gosh so you're you
asking me now for you to eat ice cream
earlier yeah you're funny what's a good
thing I said yes right
what would you done if I said no oh
you're such a lucky eight-year-old is
this the life you know what you use to
stay alive when you were excited you go
I feel so alive you can always say that
I feel so alive
live anymore and then feel relaxed oh I
feel so relaxed
so pretty bizarre week we're in Cannon
breeze room so they have a balcony this
is their their balcony view it's
gorgeous
what do you think Isaac the material
right uncle can ready with the with the
comic books
oh yeah old school reading paper print
that's old school
so originally we were gonna do a balcony
dinner you know lobster
steak some wine something fancy like
that then I realized if you don't have a
balcony and I realized the whole balcony
dinner thing was pertaining to the
actual balconies that were accommodated
with the rooms yeah I guess if you
haven't a special event or like a
special occasion
you wouldn't I guess every day yeah like
if you're two people you get a room with
a balcony like this so it can't agree
they have a balcony with a queen-size
bed but because we are a family of three
you didn't have a backup Bumpus yeah so
we have like about yeah we have the
ocean view though at least yeah that's
how we were able to do the balcony
engineer but it's okay we go
regeneration ago and now we're doing an
Italian fruit tonight yeah with the
restaurant
what are we doing out here
specialty Italian restaurant oh we need
a reservation remember
last and final surprise stage five out
of five stages of birthday surprises is
it I don't know actually made a five
stage one was the breakfast stage two
was the flowers stage three was the
present stage four was the second bottle
of champagne yes they try I'm actually
guess right Stage five dinner the best
birthday ever a big fan inebriated
[Music]
Isaac is enjoying a magic show the crew
tonight so it's just pretty much we in
Casey for my birthday dinner it's really
nice I think it's quite a success every
year his birthday happens to be on the
JK trip and it's usually in transit to
like her birthday usually happens and
we're on the plane or we're doing
something that it's just not very
convenient first day we actually
celebrate her birthday and this year
were stuck on a boat but it's not that
bad because she is a wonder list person
she loves traveling and the idea of
being out at sea this year and being
stuck on a boat in the water where she
truly loves and truly likes being
adventurous
played out so well and to have all these
different things at our disposal on his
cruise ship to create such a wonderful
day for her was perfect and I feel so
happy for her and my best success to
that in fact I'm actually kind of scared
now because make sure I don't know how
I'm gonna follow up with next year so I
gotta start planning right now for next
year you've been amazing this year the
been great perfection happy birthday to
you versatile US territory here Mexico
this place is really touristy I feel
they were awkward like we're walking
through and Mexican pee time partner
hold on a sec are you crying are you
crying Oh Ben Oh David's cry